YUFEI ZHAO: So the
first topic that I
want to discuss in this course
is extremal graph theory.
And in particular,
there is a whole class
of problems which have to do
with what happens if you forbid
a specific subgraph.
Forbid a specific subgraph.
And I ask you, what's the
maximum number of edges
that can appear in your graph?
In particular, and
this is the question
that we saw at the
end of last lecture,
which, now we're going to
pretend that's a theorem.
Mantel's theorem
essentially asks,
if you know that your graph
has no triangles, what's
the maximum number
of edges it can have?
And Mantel's theorem tells
us that the extremal example
is when your graph
consists of putting
half the vertices
on one side, half
the vertices on the
other side, and putting
in all the edges
between the two sides.
So this is a complete
bipartite graph.
For these partitions, we denote
complete bipartite graphs
like that.
And Mantel's theorem
tells us that this graph,
among triangle-free graphs,
has the most number of edges.
Triangle-free graph, n
vertices, has at most--
so the number of edges there
is n squared divided by 4.
Round down-- that many edges.
And from this example,
this bound is tight.
So Mantel's theorem
them gives us
a completely satisfactory
answer to the question of,
what's the maximum
number of edges
in a graph without triangles?
And I want to begin by showing
you a few different proofs
of Mantel's theorem.
So we're illustrating
some different techniques
in graph theory.
So we'll see quite a few
proofs in today's lecture.
The first one begins--
well, here's the setup.
I have G, an n vertex graph.
And let me denote the vertices
and edges of G by V and E.
If I have an edge in G
between vertices x and y,
then note that they cannot
have any common neighbors.
Because if they did, I
would see a triangle.
So I assume G is triangle-free.
So what can we say about
the degrees of the two
endpoints of this edge?
Well, they cannot add up to?
AUDIENCE: They can't
have more than n.
YUFEI ZHAO: They cannot
add up to more than n.
So in particular-- so exactly.
So the degrees of
these two endpoints,
there's at most n
whenever xy is an edge.
So here I'm using
d to denote degree.
Well, OK.
So now let me consider
the quantity which is
the sum of the squared degrees.
On one hand, I claim that the
sum is equal to this quantity
here, where I sum
over all edges.
And the reason is,
well, look at the sum.
Suppose, imagine writing
out all the sum n's.
How many times does
each dx come up?
So each dx appears one
for each edge x is in,
so appears exactly dx times.
But we saw from up here that
each sum n is at most n.
So this sum here
is that most mn.
On the other hand, let's
consider the quantity which
is just the sum of the degrees.
And you sometimes know it
as the handshaking lemma,
that the sums of the degrees is
just twice the number of edges.
Each edge is considered
twice in the sum.
Well, now we apply the
Cauchy-Schwarz inequality,
which, as you'll see many
times in this course,
although you might think of it
as a fairly simple inequality,
it's extremely powerful.
And it will come up pretty
much throughout this course.
By the Cauchy-Schwarz
inequality,
you compare these
two quantities.
I find that we have this
inequality over here relating
the sums of the
degrees and square
of the sum of the degrees.
But we saw, on one hand, the
left-hand side is 4m squared.
And we also saw that
the right-hand side
is at most mn squared.
Putting them together, we see
that m is at most n squared
over 4.
And of course, because
it's an integer,
it's at most the
floor of this number.
And that's a proof
of Mantel's theorem.
What can you tell me about the
equality case in this proof?
So I'll let you
think about that.
But let me show you
some other proofs.
In other words, are there
graphs with the same number
of edges as the graph
shown up there that
is also triangle-free?
Is that a unique example?
So let me show you a different
proof of Mantel's theorem.
In this proof, so
we begin with a step
that seems a little tricky.
Let's let A be a
subset of vertices such
that A is a largest
independent set of G.
So remember, independent
set is a subset of vertices
with no edges inside.
It may have many
independent sets all having
the same maximum size.
Take one of them.
So why should you do this step?
Well, you know,
sometimes magic happens.
Let's consider some vertex.
So consider some
vertex, let's say x,
and look at its neighborhood.
The neighborhood must
be an independent set.
Otherwise, I get a triangle.
So every neighborhood
is an independent set.
And as a result, the
degree of every vertex
is at most the size of the
largest independent set.
So now, let B be the complement
of A. So I have this A and B.
Every edge has to intersect
B. The edge cannot be entirely
containing A, because
it has no edges.
So the number of edges
of G is at most--
well, I count over the
vertices in B, the degree.
So maybe I overcount.
So the edges containing B, I
count twice, but that's OK.
So this is an upper bound
on the number of edges.
But I also know that
every vertex in the graph
has a degree at
most the size of A.
So each sum n is at most the
size of A. And I have B terms.
So I have that.
Now, by the AMGM inequality,
you'll have that.
And the sizes of A and B
add up to the entire vertex
set, n squared over 4.
So that gives you another
proof of Mantel's theorem.
What does this proof tell
us about the equality case?
Now, something I always want
you to keep in mind when
we do proofs is,
especially if we
have a tight example like that--
and later on in the course,
we'll almost never have
good examples like that.
So this is still early
on in the course.
And we're still very clean
in the examples-- is to keep
the extremal example in mind.
And every step in
your proof, it should
be tight for that example.
Otherwise, something went
wrong with your proof.
Let's think about
the inequalities.
At equality, we must have that--
so looking at this inequality.
So there are no edges in
B. We also have that--
so by that, so every vertex in
B is complete to A. And finally,
A and B should
have the same size.
So it is exactly the
configuration shown up there.
Now, when n is odd,
we're rounding down by 1.
So you can lose a little bit.
But you can check
that actually what
we described up there is
also the unique example.
So that graph, the
complete bipartite graph
with two equal parts, is
the unique maximal example,
number of edges in a
triangle-free graph.
Great.
So once we know
what the answer is
for triangle-free, of course,
we should ask further questions.
Instead of forbidding
a triangle,
what if we forbid other graphs?
And what are some natural
next steps to take?
Well, say, instead of triangles,
we can ask, what about if we
forbid a K4, a clique
of four vertices?
Or in general, what if we
forbid a clique on the fixed
number of vertices?
So what is the maximum number
of edges in a Kr plus 1-free--
there's a good reason
why index is r plus 1--
graph on n vertices.
So for example, if we're
interested in K4-free--
so what might be a good
candidate for a graph with lots
of edges that has no K4's?
I mean, certainly,
that example we saw,
it does not have K4's, because
it doesn't have any triangles.
But we can do even better.
Instead of taking two parts,
you can take more parts.
For K4, if I take
three parts, each
with n/3 number of
vertices, of course,
if n is not divisible by
3, round up and run down.
And putting all the edges
between different parts,
you can see this
graph here has no K4.
So that's an example
of a K4-free graph.
Well, does it have the maximum
possible number of edges?
So is this the best
that we can do?
So it turns out
the answer is yes.
And that's the next
theorem that we'll see.
But just to give it a name, so
we're going to call graphs like
these Turán graphs.
So the next theorem
is proved by Turán.
It's Turán's theorem.
So a Turán graph, so
we'll denote T sub nr.
It is a complete
r-partite graph such
that there are n
vertices whose part sizes
are all nearly the same,
up to at most 1 difference.
So this is an example here.
But in general, maybe
you have r parts.
And I put in all the edges
between different parts.
So it's not too hard to
calculate the number of edges
in such a graph.
And Turán's theorem tells
us that that is the extremal
example.
You cannot do better in
terms of getting more edges.
So if G is an n vertex, try
a K sub r plus 1-free graph.
Then it has at most the number
of edges of the Turán graph.
It's a generalization
of Mantel's theorem.
And well, you can think about
if the proofs that we did
for Mantel's generalizes
to Turán's theorem.
And it's actually not
entirely clear how to do it.
So let me present for you
three different proofs
of Turán's theorem.
So some of them,
you can think about,
are they related to the
proofs of Mantel's theorem
that we did?
And they all are going to look
somewhat different, but maybe
superficially.
The first proof, we
will use induction
on the number of vertices.
So actually, this is one of the
very few times in this course
where we will see induction.
So of course, induction
is a powerful technique
in combinatorics.
But for almost the
rest of the course,
we're not going to
have clean examples.
And when we do have clean
examples to work with,
somehow increasing n by 1
doesn't buy you all that much.
Here, there are very clean
examples, very clean answers,
and induction works
out quite well.
When n is small, of course,
you should always address that.
You can come up with
many funny proofs
if you don't address
when n is small.
So when n is small, this
problem is basically trivial.
n is almost r.
You could have the complete
graph on r vertices.
And then we're good.
So let's assume that
we're not in this case.
And also, by
induction hypothesis,
let's assume that it is true
for all graphs fewer than n
vertices.
And let G be a graph
that is K sub r
plus 1-free on n vertices.
And also, let's assume a
maximum example to begin with.
So let's assume that
the G that you chose
has already the maximum
possible number of edges.
There are only finite
of any such examples.
So pick one that already has
the maximum number of edges.
And let's think about what
properties this graph G has.
I claim that G must already
contain a clique on r vertices.
So think about that.
If G does not contain
a clique on r vertices,
then I can add in more edges.
And I can still
maintain the property
of being K sub r plus 1-free.
So I can assume that G
must contain a K sub r.
So let's look at one
of these K sub r's.
So let n be the vertices
of some r clique in G.
So we have some A. And
the complement to that,
let me call that B.
Look at the vertex in B. How
many neighbors can have in A?
It cannot be complete to A,
otherwise I would have an r
plus 1 clique.
So every vertex in B has at
most r minus 1 neighbors in A.
So let's count all the edges.
The number of edges
in G is that most--
well, first, we should account
for the edges inside A.
And there are-- or
choose two of them.
And then the edges between
A and B, for every vertex
in B, there are at most
r minus 1 vertices going
to A for each vertex in B. And
finally, the edge set of B.
Well, we can say something
more about these quantities.
We know that the size of
B is exactly n minus r.
But what can we say about
the number of edges in B?
We can use induction hypothesis.
So B is also r
plus 1 clique-free.
So the number of edges is
at most the number of edges
in a corresponding Turán graph.
Now, at this point, you
can do a calculation.
Well, I mean, you should
expect that the answer
we're looking for is--
I mean, this should be
equal to the number of edges
in the Turán graph.
So you can either
do a calculation
to figure this out,
or remember what
I said earlier, that keep
the tight example in mind,
and everything should check
out for the tight example.
So in particular, if
you are in the situation
of a complete multipartite
graph with equal size or nearly
equal-size parts, what is A?
So A is one vertex
from each part.
So you take out one
vertex from each part.
And read off this calculation
for this graph over here.
And then you see that
that is indeed equality.
So it should check out.
You don't need to do
any actual calculations.
Any questions about the
proofs we've done so far?
All right.
Let me show you another
proof of Turán's theorem.
So this proof has a name.
So it's called Zykov's
symmetrization.
So Zykov has the
unfortunate honor
of having a name
that's hard to beat
in terms of alphabetical order.
I think, if he and I
were to write a paper,
I wouldn't be the last author.
So what's this about?
So let G be the graph.
Again, as before, we're going
to take a maximal example.
So be the n-vertex graph
that is free of cliques
of r plus 1 vertices and has
already the maximum number
of edges.
So here's the property I want
to prove about this graph.
I claim that if you look at
the complement of the graph,
of this extremal
example, it must
be an equivalence relation.
So more precisely, claim
that if xy is a non-edge,
and yz is a non-edge, then
xz must also be a non-edge.
So in other words, non-edges
form equivalence relation.
And again, you
should always think
about the extremal example.
And it is true for
the extremal example.
Because the complement
are a bunch of cliques.
So it is an
equivalence relation.
So let's prove this claim.
So let's assume that the
conclusion is not true.
So suppose, for the contrary,
that we have xy and yz being
non-edges, but xz is an edge.
So let's think
about what happens
to the degrees of
non-adjacent vertices.
So I claim that
if the degree of y
were smaller than
the degree of x, then
I can do something
to the graph that
violates the maximality
of the number of edges.
Namely, I can replace
y by a clone of x.
So I chop off y from the graph.
And I look at x.
And I clone.
So cloning it means
taking some x prime.
And I join x prime to all
the same neighbors as x.
So clone x into some
other vertex, x prime.
Now, when you do this,
I claim that you also
get a graph that is
free of K sub r plus 1.
So we also obtain a K
sub r plus 1-free graph.
So why is that?
So if you were to have
an r plus 1 clique,
well, it shouldn't have
both x and x clone.
Because there's no
edge between them.
So it only has one
of x and x clone.
But then that would have been
a clique in the original graph.
However, what about
the number of edges
that we obtain after
this transformation?
If x had more outgoing
edges, a higher degree
than y, then cloning
x to replace y
increases the number of edges.
We obtain a graph that is
also K sub r plus 1-free
and has more edges than
G, which is not possible,
because we assumed that g
started with the maximum number
of edges.
So therefore, the degree of y is
at most the degree x, basically
for every non-edge xy.
Likewise, we also
have that there
is no edge between y and z.
So the degree of y is--
thus the degree of y is at
least the degree of x now.
So degree of y is at
least the degree of z.
Now, y has a lot
of outgoing edges.
So now let's replace both
x and z by clones of y.
As before, we obtain some
graph that we'll call G prime.
And G prime, same reason as
before, is K sub r plus 1-free.
If you had a K sub r plus
1, then the same clique
should have shown up in
G. So G prime does not
have r plus 1 cliques either.
But what about the number
of edges in G prime?
So the number of
edges in G prime--
well, we started with
G. We deleted x and z.
So we deleted this many edges.
Here, we're crucially
using the fact
that there is an
edge between x and z.
But now we also added
back in a bunch of edges
coming from the clone of y.
And they are 2 times
dy edges added back in.
Now, you see, because y
has degree at least that
of both x and z, we obtain
that this number of edges
is strictly bigger than
that of G, which contradicts
the maximality of G.
So at this point, we know
that the complement of G
must be an equivalence relation.
So the complement is
a bunch of cliques.
And that's a lot of information.
So that's almost
the best thing we
can hope for is the
structural information.
We're not quite done yet.
And why is that?
Well, we're almost there.
But we're not quite done yet.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you can figure out
the sizes [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So we need to figure out the
sizes of the individual parts.
sizes of individual parts.
And also, note that you
cannot have too many parts.
So at this point,
after the claim,
we know that G is a
complete multipartite graph.
It has at most r parts.
If it had r plus 1 parts,
I would see a clique
in r plus 1 vertices.
So then, finally,
I need to show--
I mean, the rest
is fairly routine.
I need to show what
the part sizes have
to be to maximize
the number of edges.
And basically, if you
had some two parts--
so consider exactly r parts.
They're all empty parts.
And some two parts
have the number
of vertices differing
by more than 1.
Then what I can do is--
so if you had one part much
bigger than the other part,
you can imagine moving
one vertex from one part
to the other part.
And you should convince yourself
that this operation should
strictly increase
the number of edges.
And then moving vertices
should strictly increase
the number of edges of G.
And putting this
all together, we
see that the extremal
example necessarily
has to be the
current graph, namely
a complete r-partite
graph, where
all the parts have
the same size, up
to almost 1 difference.
Great.
Any questions?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Can the Zykov
symmetrization technique
be used for any other
type of problem?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the question is,
can the Zykov symmetrization
technique be used for any
other types of problem?
I do have something
else in mind.
But I don't want
to discuss it now.
Any more questions?
Great.
And you see that in both proofs,
if you look at this proof
as well, you see
that the Turán graph,
it's the unique extremizer.
I want to give you a
third proof that has
a somewhat different flavor.
So these two proofs,
they're both somewhat
combinatorial in flavor.
So I'm doing some arguments
either looking at,
in this case, a
clique and arguing
what happens outside of it.
And over there, again, I'm
looking at maximal example.
The third proof
I want to show is
more of a probabilistic proof.
So this highlights an important
method in combinatorics,
and almost a
probabilistic method,
where we start with a problem
that comes with no randomness.
But we introduce some randomness
to make the problem amenable.
It's a very pretty idea.
So we start, again, with G being
a n-uniform, so n-vertex, K sub
r plus 1-free graph on m edges.
And what I want to do is to
randomly sort the vertex set.
Consider a random
order of the vertices.
So I put all the
vertices on the line,
but the vertices are
chosen at random order.
And you see some of
the edges like that.
Let me show you how
to find a clique.
And essentially, we do
it in a not-so-smart way.
Namely, I basically
pick all the vertices
in some greedy-like
manner, where
I include the vertex
in my set if it
is adjacent to all
earlier vertices.
So if all of its neighbors--
so I include V, if
V is the earliest
vertex among its neighbors.
So earliest means the leftmost,
so if I go from left to right.
So in this case up here, so
I look at the first vertex.
Well, the first vertex
should always be in your set.
So this vertex has one
neighbor, just to the right.
So that's OK.
And hold on.
It's-- no.
Sorry.
That's not what I want to do.
So I actually do mean what I was
going to write down initially.
So if V is adjacent to
all the earlier vertices
in this order--
so for example, this
vertex, it's OK.
And I'm also going to
include this vertex here,
because both of its
earlier vertices are in--
both the earlier vertices are
adjacent to the third vertex.
And I think that's it.
Now, this set x, I
claim two things.
One, that x has to be a clique.
So claim that x
has to be a clique.
Because every vertex in
the x is adjacent to all
of the [INAUDIBLE]
vertices in particular.
All the vertices in x
are joined to each other.
On the other hand, how big is
x, at least in expectation?
So for every vertex, I want
to understand the probability
that this v is included in x.
So v has a bunch
of non-neighbors.
And the property of
v being included in x
is that all of its
non-neighbors appear after v.
So the probability that v,
little v, is in the set x
is equal to the
probability that v appears
before all its non-neighbors.
All v and its non-neighbors,
they're sorted uniformly.
So the probability that this
occurs is exactly 1 over 1
plus the number
of non-neighbors,
which is n minus the degree of.
Well, we know that
this graph G has
no cliques of size r plus 1.
So if we consider the expected
number of the size of x,
on one hand, it is at most r.
Because G K sub r plus 1-free.
On the other hand, by
linearity of expectations,
each vertex is included
with some probability.
So the size of x in
expectation is just
a sum of all of these individual
inclusion probabilities, which
individually we've
computed above like that.
Now, by convexity,
I can conclude
that this quantity, this sum
here, is at least the quantity
that would have been obtained
if all the decrease were
equal to each other.
And if you rearrange this
equation, this inequality,
we obtain that an m
is at most 1 minus 1
over r times n squared over 2.
And if you compare this
number to the number of edges
in the Turán graph, so you
see that this is basically
the number of edges, and this
gives you a proof if n is
divisible by r.
And in fact, the number of edges
in the Turán graph is exactly
this number here, if this
divisibility condition is true.
If it's not, you need to
do a little bit more work.
Because we were a little
bit lost here in this step.
So you should see that
this quantity here
is minimized when all
the degrees are roughly
equal to each
other, and you make
them as close to each
other as possible.
So with a little bit more work,
you can get the exact version
of Turán's theorem up there.
But at least what
we've shown is--
so from here, we've shown that
the number of edges is at most
this quantity, which,
for most purposes,
is basically as good
as Turán's theorem.
Any questions about
this proof here?
And so it's a probabilistic
method of proof.
So we're introducing
some randomness
into the problem that
originally had no randomness.
Great.
So let's take a very
quick 2-minute break.
And then when we come back,
I want to show you that even
though we've shown so
many different proofs
of Turán's theorem and Mantel's
theorem-- you might think, OK,
this is a pretty simple thing--
even if I tweak the
problem just a little bit,
there are so many things
that we do not understand,
and many important open problems
in combinatorics that are
variants of Turán's theorem.
So let's take a quick break.
So so far we've been talking
about Turán's theorem,
or generally the problem of, if
you forbid a certain structure,
forbid a certain subgraph, what
is the maximum number of edges?
We're going to spend the
next few lectures discussing
more problems of that form.
And it turns out, for the
answers we've just seen,
they are deceptively simple.
And for almost any
other situation,
we don't really know
the exact answer.
And for many questions, we
don't know anything close
to the truth.
And in particular,
I want to show you
one variant of this
problem, namely
what happens, instead
of looking at graphs,
if you look at hypergraphs.
And there, that's a major
open problem in combinatorics,
what the truth should be.
So here is an open
problem, which is,
what happens to Turán's theorem
for 3-uniform hypergraphs?
So don't be scared by
the word hypergraph.
So whereas you think of graphs
as having edges consisting
of pairs of vertices,
a hypergraph
is simply a structure where,
for a 3-uniform hypergraph,
the edges are triples,
triples of vertices.
So the question is, what is
the maximum number of triples
in 3-uniform
hypergraph without--
well, for Mantel's
theorem, we asked what
happens without a triangle.
For a 3-uniform, the
basic question you can ask
is, what about
forbidding a tetrahedral?
So suppose you do
have four vertices
such that every triple inside
the four vertices is a niche.
What's the maximum
number of edges
you can have in an n-vertex,
3-uniform hypergraph.
Already, it's not so easy to
come up with good examples.
So Turán's theorem says
take a bipartite graph,
complete bipartite graph.
Well, here, it's not so easy
to come up with examples,
but there are some examples.
And in fact, Turán suggested
the following construction.
Namely, you divide the set
of vertices, as before,
to three roughly
equal-sized parts.
And let me take all triples that
look like one of the following
forms, either three vertices,
one in each vertex set,
or a triple, looking
like that-- two
vertex in one set,
one in the next set,
or going cyclically, like that.
So I include all triples,
one of these forms.
And you should check
that this construction
has no tetrahedron.
If it had a
tetrahedron, you would
have had at least two
vertices in one part, also
then where the other
two vertices can be.
If you check that,
it cannot happen.
So then, how many
edges does it have?
The exact number is
not so important.
But what's important is
that the edge density--
of all the possible
triples, the fraction
of edges that are containing
this construction is 5/9.
And it is conjectured
that this is optimal.
However, we're quite far
from proving this number.
So the best upper bound that
is currently available--
and it's found quite recently
using this fairly new method
in graph theory called
flag algebras, essentially
a computerized way to try
to prove such inequalities.
And the best upper bound
is something like 0.562.
And there's a major open problem
to either prove or disprove
that this construction
here is the optimal one.
So you see, even though I
presented so many proofs
of Mantel's theorem and
Turán's theorem, at this point,
hopefully they should all be--
they seem quite
simple in retrospect.
It's deceptive.
And even if I changed and tweak
the problem just a little bit,
going to 3-uniform
hypergraph instead of graphs,
we really have no
idea what's going on.
Yes?
Question?
AUDIENCE: So
basically, how do you--
why you say that this is really
bad compared to a two-number?
It doesn't seem like
that big a difference.
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So great.
So the question is, why do
I say it's a pretty big gap.
So we know that there
has to be some proportion
of the total number of triples.
So, well, you have two numbers.
And well, I mean, to me,
they seem pretty far apart.
It's not some lower-order gap.
So this is a first-order gap.
Any more questions?
But it's true that
later in the course,
we'll see gaps that
are much bigger.
We'll see gaps where there's
a polynomial on one side
and a power of exponentials
on the other side.
And there, I agree,
that's much worse.
The gap is much bigger.
Here, it's just two numbers.
But in the worst case, there
can be two numbers anywhere.
Any more questions?
So throughout this
course, I will
try to bring out
some open problems.
And there are lots.
So I will tell you
what we do understand.
But most things, we
do not understand.
And hopefully, some of
you will go out and try
to understand them better so the
next time I teach the course,
I could have something
new to present.
So now that we've addressed
the question of what's
the maximum number of
edges if you forbid
a triangle or a clique, the
next natural thing to ask
is, what about if you
forbid a general H?
So give me a graph H. And what's
the maximum number of edges
if you forbid that H?
It will be helpful
to do some notation.
So the extremal number,
which we'll denote by ex,
and this is also called
the Turán number sometimes
because of Turán's theorem.
So I'll probably call it
the extremal number more
frequently.
So this number here is defined
to be the maximum number
of edges in an n-vertex
graph containing no copy of H
as a subgraph.
I want to just clarify
a piece of notation.
So when I say a subgraph,
so what do I mean?
So there are several notions of
different kinds of subgraphs.
And a couple that come
up somewhat frequently,
one is subgraph.
And then there's something
called induced subgraph.
So it's probably easiest if
I just show you an example.
So suppose my H
is the four cycle.
So in the example of
H being a subgraph,
suppose I have this graph here.
So H is a subgraph of this graph
here in many different ways,
but in particular, like that.
But you see there are
some more edges that
are among the vertices.
But that's OK.
So subgraph only requires you
to have a subset of vertices
and a subset of edges,
whereas induced subgraphs--
this is not an example
of induced subgraph.
And so induced
subgraph means that you
take this set of
vertices and you
look at all the edges
in the big graph
among your set of vertices.
So that's an induced subgraph.
So here, the four cycle is
an induced subgraph, but not
induced subgraph over here.
So I just want to make
that distinction clear.
And for now, in
this chapter, we'll
only talk about subgraphs--
so not induced, necessarily.
All right.
So let's recap what happened
for Turán's theorem.
So Turán's theorem told us that
the extremal number of these
cliques, well, we know very
precisely to be the number
of edges in the Turán graph.
And in particular, we saw
from the last proof, but also,
similarly, if you
just do a calculation,
that it is at most this
quantity over here.
And it's basically
that quantity.
So the number of edges in this
Turán graph is asymptotically
that quantity up to
a lower-order error;
if you like n go to
infinity, r fixed.
And the basic question
is, what about general H?
And so if I give you some
arbitrary graph H, what can you
tell me about the
maximum number of edges
in the graph forbidding
this H as a subgraph?
And it turns out, for most
H's, we have a pretty good
understanding, and perhaps
quite surprisingly,
because you can
imagine this problem
looks like it might
get quite complicated.
All the proofs that we've done
are very specific to cliques.
But it turns out that we
already understand a lot.
And the critical
parameter that governs
how this quantity behaves is
the chromatic number of H.
So if you call me the
chromatic number of H,
I can already tell
you quite a lot.
So just to remind you, the
chromatic number of a graph
is the minimum number
of colors you need
to properly color this graph.
Chromatic number of
H, denoted chi of H,
is the minimum number
of colors needed
to color the vertices of H so
that no two adjacent vertices
have the same color.
So for instance, if I give you
a clique of r plus 1 vertices,
so all the vertices must
receive different colors,
because every pair of
vertices is adjacent--
so the chromatic
number is r plus 1.
The chromatic number of
the Turán graph is what?
It's r.
So the chromatic number
of the Turán graph is r.
I can color each part in
this complete bipartite
graph using a different color.
And that's the best I can do.
Now, if I have one graph being a
subgraph of another graph, what
can you tell me about
the relationships
between their chromatic numbers?
So if H is a subgraph
of G, so what can
you tell me about
relationship between
their chromatic numbers?
AUDIENCE: Chi of H is
less than the other chi.
YUFEI ZHAO: So OK.
You're telling me that the
chi of H is at most chi of G.
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because
if G can be colored
with a certain number of colors,
then that also has [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
Whatever coloring you do for
G, you use the same coloring,
and that's a proper
coloring for H as well.
So the chromatic number
of H might be smaller,
but certainly cannot be
bigger than that of G.
So in particular, if you have a
graph H with chromatic number r
plus 1, then this Turán
on graph is always H-free.
So if H requires four
colors, it cannot be embedded
into the complete multipartite
graph of three parts.
So the Turán graph is also an
example of an H-free graph with
lots of edges.
And this tells us that the
extremal number of H is
at least that of
this Turán number,
where r is defined as the
chromatic number minus 1.
So that's some
lower-bound construction.
So as we saw
earlier, and we know
what the asymptotic is like
for the number of edges,
this n goes to infinity.
Namely, it's like that.
And now the question is,
is this the right answer?
Is it possible
that we completely
missed some construction that
might produce a lot more edges?
And it turns out--
and I think this should
be somewhat surprising.
Because so far, I feel like
I haven't told you anything
all that surprising yet.
This seems like a fairly
mysterious problem.
But it turns out that this is
more or less the right answer.
So you cannot do much
better than the Turán graph.
And there's the theorem of
Erdos, Stone, and Simonovits
rich that for every graph H--
so if I fixed H,
then the limit as n
goes to infinity of
the extremal number
is a fraction of
total number of pairs.
So here, this is
the edge density.
So this quantity here is
equal to 1 minus chi of H.
So 1 minus 1 over
chi of H minus 1.
So the chromatic
number, in some sense,
completely determines how big
the extremal number should be.
And you see that so far
everything we've proved,
Turán's theorem, Mantel's
theorem agree with this formula
here.
But if I give you some H,
maybe quite complicated,
and those previous
proofs don't work,
well, still you know the
first order asymptotics.
But there's still more to say.
But first, let me just
run through some examples
for a sanity check.
So if H is a triangle--
so if H, the chromatic
number, and this limit--
so if H is the triangle,
chromatic number is 3.
So then this limit is 1/2.
And that's indeed the case.
So that's what we did
with Mantel's theorem.
If H is a clique
of four vertices,
then the chromatic number is 4.
And the answer is 2/3.
And also, that agrees
with Turán's theorem.
It agrees with Turán's theorem.
But I can give you some
fairly complicated-looking H.
So for example, H might
be the Petersen graph.
So every good
graph theory course
should feature a Petersen
graph at least once, somewhere.
So that's the Petersen graph.
What's the chromatic number
of the Petersen graph?
Actually, that's kind
of a tricky question.
The last time I
taught this course,
I even got the answer wrong.
So it turns out you can
three-color the Petersen graph.
So it's completely not
obvious how to do this.
But there are only
so many vertices.
If you stare at it long enough,
you can see what happens.
But let me just show you a
three-coloring of the Petersen
graph.
Then the third
color is like that.
So that's a three-coloring
of the Petersen graph.
That's chromatic number 3.
It's not 2.
So why is it not 2?
AUDIENCE: It's not bipartite.
YUFEI ZHAO: It's not bipartite.
It's a five cycle, which
cannot be two-colored.
So then the limit is 1/2.
And-- no.
That's 3.
Great.
So the limit is 1/2.
And here, I think that
we can apply this theorem
of Erdos-Stone-Simonovits.
And I think this should
be somewhat surprising.
Because the Petersen graph
looks quite complicated.
If you try to forbid
this graph in some big G,
it seems like it's
kind of hard to do.
But it turns out the
chromatic number completely
governs the behavior of
the extremal numbers.
But it turns out that's
not the entire story.
Because while this is quite
a good theorem, and I said,
it gives you the
first-order asymptotics,
actually, that's a lie.
It doesn't always give you
the first-order asymptotics.
And when is
Erdos-Stone-Simonovits
not effective?
Or rather, it's
not the complete--
it's not the final answer.
Well, you can say, well,
what about this little o?
So we're still trying to
understand, there's a limit.
And you can understand
what is the--
how quickly does it converge
to this number here?
So that's certainly
a valid question.
But more importantly, though,
if your graphic is bipartite,
if chi of H equals
to 2, i.e. bipartite,
then all this
theorem tells you is
that the limit is equal
to 0, which somehow is not
the most satisfying answer.
You want to know the
first-order asymptotics.
I mean, this still
tells you something.
So the Erdos-Stone-Simonovits
theorem
tells you that the
extremal number
is little o of n squared.
But of course, no.
You are a curious mathematician.
And you want to know, really,
what is the asymptotics?
Is it like n to the 3/2?
Is it like n to the 4/3?
You know, is this
is not satisfying.
And it turns out, from
most bipartite graphs H,
it is a very difficult
problem that we still
do not know the answer
to, even what is
the order of the asymptotics.
So the next few lectures,
what I want to do
is to show you some
techniques that
will allow you to
prove some upper bounds
for this extremal
number in the case
when H is bipartite that shows
you that the exponent can
be less than 2.
And I will also show
you some constructions
that sometimes, but
in the very few cases,
matches the upper bound.
So there are very few examples
of graphs H for which we know
the first-order asymptotics.
And for most graph H, they
are major open problems
in combinatorics.
And there are some really old
ones for which any solution
may be quite exciting.
I will not show you a proof
of Erdos-Stone-Simonovits now.
We will see that
later in the term,
once we have developed
some more machinery.
Although, later on in the
term, we'll see a proof using
the so-called Szemerédi's
regularity lemma,
which I've mentioned a few
times in the first lecture.
Although, you don't actually
need such heavy machinery.
So the original proofs
of Erdos and Stone,
and also by Simonovits--
so Erdos and Stone first
proved this result for H
being a complete
multipartite graph.
And Simonovits
observed that knowing
H for a complete
multipartite graph
actually implies this
result in general.
So you will not find
a paper with all three
of them being authors.
But this is what the
theorem is called.
So later on in the course, once
we've developed the machinery
of graph regularity lemmas,
I will show you how you can
deduce Erdos-Stone-Simonovits
from Turán's theorem.
So somehow you use Turán's
theorem and bootstrap it
to Erdos-Stone-Simonovits.
So that should seem
somewhat magical.
So on one hand,
you have cliques.
On the other hand, you
have things that somehow
don't have cliques in them.
They don't really
look like cliques.
But you can still
bootstrap one to the other.
And so after we develop some
machinery, we'll do that.
But there is a
combinatorial proof
which doesn't use any
of this heavy machinery.
I won't discuss it in lecture,
but you can look it up.
And it's quite nice.
It has some
combinatorial techniques
and some double-counting
arguments.
So going forward, I want to
show you some questions, mostly
questions, but some
answers as well--
so questions such as, what
is the extremal number of--
well, so what are some of
the basic bipartite graphs?
One of them is just a
complete bipartite graph.
So this has a name.
It's called the
Zarankiewicz problem.
And for some values of s
and t, we know the answer.
But for most values, we have
no idea what the answer is.
For example for K4,4, we do
not know what is the correct
exponent on the n.
So even fairly small cases,
it is very much open.
So this is all to show you
that these simple proofs
that we did today, they are
perhaps too deceptively simple.
Because even if you change
the question a little bit,
we don't understand a lot.
So questions like
these will occupy
the next several lectures.
And I'll also show you
some constructions.
And there are some
constructions that
use nice algebraic ideas and
some probabilistic ideas.
So we'll see ideas coming
from many different sources.
I want to close off by
just a cultural remark.
So in this course,
especially the first half,
we'll encounter a lot
of Hungarian names.
So we already saw
a couple of them.
And I just want to give
you a very quick tutorial
on how to pronounce
Hungarian names, just
for cultural purposes now.
In the past, when
I took this CLASS
there were no
Hungarian speakers.
But I think we do have at
least one Hungarian speaker
in the room.
So I want you--
but you are a native
Hungarian speaker.
So you should tell us.
So can you help us
pronounce these names?
AUDIENCE: Erdos.
YUFEI ZHAO: Erdos.
And this one?
AUDIENCE: That doesn't
seem like a Hungarian name.
[LAUGHTER]
YUFEI ZHAO: So this,
Hungarian, it's Simonovits.
So I'll just tell you two
things about Hungarian names.
One of them is that the S--
AUDIENCE: It's /sh/.
YUFEI ZHAO: --is
pronounced like /sh/.
And another thing
that comes up is S-Z,
which we saw in Szemerédi.
So this is pronounced like /s/.
Forget the Z.
So Erdos, another thing about
Erdos that you should know
is that--
what is this accent?
It is not a double dot.
So in LaTeX you would
type it as slash H,
and in particular,
not like that.
So just a few cultural
remarks about names.
Great.
So we'll end today.
And then next time,
we'll start looking
at other extremal numbers
for more bipartite graphs.